Florida has become the sixth state to
enact school choice into law that's
after West Virginia Arizona Iowa Utah
Arkansas now we've got Florida why is
Florida doing this one because Rhonda
Santos is a very good governor and he's
obviously running for president so he's
going to score as many wins on that
board as he can before he formally
announces but what explains the push in
all of these other states why School
choices become more popular because
Republicans have been talking about
school choice for ever why is it now the
the consensus wisdom is that the reason
that school choice is winning now is
because during lockdown the kids came
home and the parents were able to see
what they were being taught in schools
because the the learning started to take
place on laptops and the parents could
be in the back of the room and the
parents were so shocked at what the kids
were being taught in schools that this
renewed a push for school choice